Hey it's me, Destin. I'm in Baltimore.
[Mascot blows raspberries]
[Destin laughs]
Thanks.
[Music]
So let's say you want to make
yourself smarter on electronics,
but you're not, uh...
You're not really swoofed
on that kinda stuff.
Oh, looky here, it's the
National Electronics Museum.
Why don't we go have a look?
John McCarty is here. He's
a volunteer at the museum.
We have a demonstration for you
to show you the relation between
current flow and magnetism.
So there's a magenet right here,
on this side of this tube.
We have a coil of wire
hooked up to a galvanometer,
basically, that's measuring amps.
It's set up for DC amps.
So when we twist this, the magnet's
gonna fall through the coil
and you'll get current flow here.
So you can see the current spike.
So here's the question: when
we turn it the other way,
are we going to get positive
current or negative current?
So that's the question.
So if you think it's gonna be positive
- if the needle's gonna go that way,
click here.
If you think the needle's gonna
go that way, click here,
and afterwards we'll get
Mr. McCarty to explain it, so...
Click now.
[Music]
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help.